founder of Khan Academy Sal Khan
believes that AI can bring the biggest
positive change to education that we've
ever seen in his recent Vancouver Ted
Talk he demonstrated the ability of his
new chat bot called conmigo utilizing AI
to outperform tutors in the domains of
math computer programming and even
English he then switched his generative
AI to teacher mode demonstrating how
teachers can utilize this Tech to become
more efficient and prioritize their
human interactions with students the
biggest takeaway here seems to be the
economic Factor not all students can
afford tutors by harnessing the power of
the large language model designed
specifically for this purpose we can
help all students have a better
education regardless of their financial
situation let me know what you guys
think and as always let's continue to
digest AI